if I was telling a kid right now I'd say
brother unless brother sister unless
there's a super serious thing you can
get a degree in that you can exchange
for your green rectangles don't go yeah
cuz all these P half the people going in
right now are getting decreased that
mean nothing anytime you see kids
looking up at Bernie Sanders in the same
way you see those young girls at the
Sullivan Show looking at the Beatles the
world's gone horribly you see those kids
and I think are you kidding me this is
the guy we used to avoid his lawn cuz
nobody knew if he had buckshot loaded up
all of a sudden he's he's suitable it it
makes me laugh Bernie Sanders can't
believe he's pulled it off what do you
think the obsession with politics is
like that kind of thing you're right
it's yeah you think that's that's it
more listen out when you get to a point
and for kids I know they're going to
talk about health care but I by and
large I don't think kids in their 20s
they're always so invincible are
thinking and I'm gonna have a goiter
when I'm 70 is it going to be covered I
don't think they work that way I do
think a lot of kids are getting out of
college now with the north of a hundred
or hi tens school loan they can't even
get off the pad in their eighties it's
almost like they're working with loan
sharks yeah they gotta pay that off
before they can get to their dreams
therefore they think [ __ ] my dreams I'm
not gonna have in a house I'm gonna live
in a small micro apartment I'm not gonna
get a car I'm gonna bike around or pick
up one of these jerk-off scooters on
every corner and I'm gonna go out once a
week with my friends and film the
Michelob commercial we're all sitting
around we're all putting our beer on top
of the turntable and I'm gonna pay for a
great class of Y because I don't have
any options on getting a house or a car
and I think all that's happened is if I
was a kid and I was sitting there with a
hundred grand worth of school loans and
it was for an environmental studies
degree where Craig frankly I went out
and they said here's some
some dishwashing solution go clean that
dove up on the beach I'd be saying who's
the guy wants to forgive my love I'd
probably be gone there but I'm not
anymore I'm an old guy who had minimal
school loans paid him off and they can't
expect me to go back and see it that way
I don't want to give up everything for
people who if I was telling a kid right
now I'd say the brother and listen
brother sister unless there's a super
serious thing you can get a degree in
that you can exchange for your green
rectangles don't go yeah cuz all these P
half the people going in right now are
getting degrees that mean nothing and
you could have 4 years on the ground
find out what you want get in there get
into whatever the equivalent of the mail
room is spend those 4 years you know
Jesus for God's sakes about 1,500 days
while they're sitting in there you know
I got holding seances and stuff like
this where you can be out there building
a resume where the boss goes that kid
busts his ass so when the college kid
gets out and comes in yo I've got a
degree I was in student government and
the guy has to pretend well that's right
I think it is one end up in a lawsuit
he's thinking I got this kid busting his
ass for four years I'm gonna give him
the gig so I think politics right now
for young people come down to school
loans what do you think of the other guy
we spoke for 40 minutes ago Levin said
that no the t words oh we can do by then
let's do by to wear you out with Biden
we didn't talk about Trump yet it's been
40 minutes locally well yeah let's do
let's do bye listen I I've always made
fun of I you know I I think he's anybody
who gets in at 29 and is now 77 as
inviting guys like me to make fun of oh
yeah I know he's helping me Joey you
know I don't need you know is he helping
you out of the open he always talks
about how I've been in public service oh
okay yeah thanks for helping but you
know III don't dig guys who get off who
quite frankly get off their old man's
nickel on to the public dime and their
late 20s ride it all the way and it
always bored me with Jerry Brown you
know he's pitching himself as you know
an ethereal creature and I always think
brother you've been on the teat for like
forever six decade now
okay so don't tell me about what a free
form you are but Biden has never been as
smart as they told me it was or he told
you he was anybody who knows their IQs a
big tell for me two things when a guy
you're golfing with goes into the woods
and you get to the green you go what you
get and he pulls his hand up I know he's
[ __ ] and whatever guy says I know my
IQ I go cry I I don't like that to begin
with I go why why do you know your IQ
that insecure you're faking it that much
fighting is one of those guys who knows
his own IQ and I never saw him as a
genius I always think of Joe Biden is
the third guy in a car on a sonic
commercial you know just popping up and
I love the tater tots - so he's no
genius and but now he looks addled yeah
what do you think of that I mean it does
it something is seriously wrong I'm sort
of subdural haematoma years ago right
yeah but it's only in the last he had
that something like 20 years examinees
office feed they're gonna push him ahead
you might get elected I'll tell you what
it'll never go on a debate stage with
Trump he'll never do that and I can hear
the whole thing they'll put it on
prompter for him ago I would not
normalize this man by being on the same
stage with him it would be beneath my
dignity but more importantly more
employment Lee beneath the dignity of
the American people and it will get all
tied up and poignant Lee and end up you
know in a straitjacket they won't even
know they'll have to come out and get
him offstage but they'd vote him in
because they hate Trump that much I
think he's by the board's I don't think
he was all that much to begin with
I don't like back slappers I don't like
glad handers I don't like that core
[ __ ] about I I walked through the
diner today and he find out the diner
hasn't been there in 20 years you know I
the Biden's just never impressed me to
me he's always been more unhinge than a
rescue dog and Phil Spector's house so
where we get the the Trump guy do you
think a good person like actually like
sort of an enlightened decent human
being could ever be part of this thing
it seems like the ship has pretty much
sailed on that although I think a great
reckoning could be coming maybe to our
whole political it'll be so cataclysmic
it remains to me unimaginable ya know I
think it is automatic I don't know if
it'll be 29 where all of a sudden the
Dow you know it's happy
now because of the virus but I'm just
saying it'll either be 1929 or 1860
something like that the unimaginable you
don't want to be the first guy in
Section C a civil war coming they'll
make you out to be the bad yeah but
seriously for the reset that happened I
don't see it being incremental I see
something just the shy of cataclysmic
happening
maybe Corona is it I don't know but if
anybody thinks the Dems are gonna solve
Corona after what I just saw in their
own caucus is in Iowa I don't know that
I want to hand it off to them
but I don't see it coming back around I
see it getting very tribal and I can
only hope at some point we divvy up the
albums like the relationship that's gone
it's like Woody Allen in Annie Hall we
got a dead shark here Zoey used to say
yeah yeah and what we got here is a dead
shark and divvy the albums up so what
does that mean though what does that
actually mean like what does that look
like we divvy up the albums what meaning
what we're in we should split up in my
mind I don't see it coming back around I
don't know how to do that that doesn't
work out very well for guys like me and
you in California you know you move I
don't even know if it's Geographic I
don't know what I'm saying you know
people exactly I'm telling you I think
at this point we got a dead shark and I
don't quite know how we figure it out
but at some point we shouldn't try to go
closer together cuz that's only gonna
make it more rancorous we don't get
along we don't even agree I I tell you
one thing I do notice is I find people
I've been on the right and I've been on
the left as far as issues in my life
I've also been thought of as somebody's
on the left and on the right mistakenly
over my life I find the left is really
more brutal than the right I mean I used
to tear people within the conservative
community a new [ __ ] when I'd meet
him that kind of nice laugh about it
yeah and the left man it dangerous you
know you're gonna catch a d-cell on a
tube sock if you don't agree and so
that's why I put periodically were you
kind of shocked though when you first
started seeing that like you first go on
O'Reilly maybe happen then I wasn't Mort
Sahl wrote a great book years ago called
heartland and I think when people think
back on Mort Sahl they always think of
his
probably because he was Sancho Panza or
Boswell to Kennedys Jack there what am I
thinking
Boswell's sam johnson to kennedy sam
johnson he was a chronicler and he liked
being in the with the cool kids but he
started to see it and he started talking
about liberalism and he was a real
hipster boy I don't even know Mort still
up there
maybe he's past but no no he's still
alive unless something happened last
week I'm 99% he just started having that
epiphany I remember it happened with
Stockdale
I remember everybody's making fun of
stock there and I think McCain had told
me once the stock tale when he was in
the Hanoi Hilton
when kids given up and they were gonna
kill themselves he would get on the pipe
at night and tap it with a flint to pray
with them in sign language to convince
them not to die that night Wow like
something that maybe what thousand men
in the history of planet have been
consequential enough to do and then he's
on cable when he goes I don't even know
why I learned everybody makes him an
[ __ ] and I thought this room's got to
hip for me man if we're gonna start like
talking about Stockdale like he's an
idiot and Nancy Pelosi is a viable
player I just thought I can't be in the
live today they asked too much of the
lockstep if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about comedy instead of the non-stop
yelling you get everywhere else check
out our comedy playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlists they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell